this is Shaq on the Great Wall of China
here's Michael Jordan Pau Gasol
Steph Curry there are a lot of these
four years the NBA has been sending
teams to China where more people watch
NBA games than in the United States the
purpose is to play basketball meet
Chinese fans and have players like Rip
Hamilton spread a clear message the NBA
has worked hard to build a successful
business in China but then they almost
lost it all because of a single tweet it
was March of 2000 and President Clinton
was pushing for a trade deal with China
despite concerns about China's human
rights record it does deny citizens
fundamental rights of free speech and
religious expression it does define its
interest in the world and sometimes in
ways that are dramatically at odds from
our own just a decade before China's
government put down an uprising at
Tiananmen Square and in 1999 Americans
also had concerns about China's record
in Taiwan and Tibet this is wrong it's
gotta stop
President Clinton we are asking you to
take a courageous position but Clinton
insisted that doing business with China
would have a positive impact on their
human rights platform the question is
not whether we approve or disapprove of
China some practices the question is
what's the smartest thing to do to
improve
these practices Bill Clinton came to
think that engagement that trade that
direct contact would have a positive
impact on the human rights situation in
China as well as improving the overall
us-china relationship the next year
China joined the WTO 2001 is important
because that's when the country enters
into the World Trade Organization which
greatly simplifies doing business not
just with the United States but with the
entire world the Chinese economy was
about to take off
US businesses began investing in China
and eventually Chinese companies would
start investing back in the US as China
became richer as China became more
integrated into the global economy it
became a more important market for the
United States after 2001 the average
Chinese person had more disposable
income as a result of the rapid growth
it was the perfect moment for the NBA to
build a business in China and it all
started right here Yao Ming from
Shanghai
at the time Yao Ming was 21 years old
watching the NBA Draft on a laptop in
China for the NBA would it mean would be
the NBA number one overall yah was the
NBA's next big thing for fans in China
where basketball has been popular ever
since it was introduced by missionaries
in the 19th century when the Communist
Party came to power they banned most
Western sports but basketball was
embraced as a national passion but China
never produced a star player until Yao
[Music]
now they could watch a Chinese player
playing at the same level of these
legendary grades and playing shaft 200
million Chinese viewers tuned in for his
first game against Shaq and the Lakers
[Applause]
compare that to nine point nine million
the average number of Americans that
watch the NBA Finals that you
[Music]
yow became a household name in China and
soon American companies turned to him
for endorsements can Jimmy play the new
17-inch Yahoo's popularity also helped
the NBA develop their fan base there in
2004 the NBA started sending teams on an
annual summer tour of China where the
Houston Rockets became a fan favorite
simply because that was Yas team the
tour's brought the biggest NBA players
to China and boosted the league's
popularity for comparison the NBA has
slightly more Twitter followers than the
next major sports league in the United
States but in China the NBA dominates
social media platforms like Weibo nearly
500 million people watched NBA games
last year using $0.10 China's largest
streaming platform that's more than the
entire population of the United States
in 2019 $0.10 and the NBA signed a deal
worth one and a half billion dollars
almost three times what it was worth
five years ago the people who manage the
NBA recognized that there were
tremendous opportunities in China and
they worked hard to develop that market
and they have succeeded then seven words
threatened everything Daryl Morey is the
general manager of the Houston Rockets
and his tweet repeated a phrase chanted
by protesters in Hong Kong well this is
just about civil liberties this is about
having a voice in government what's
wrong with that and so he thought
nothing of tweeting this out whereas in
China it was perceived quite differently
it was seen as an effort to break up
China an effort to weaken China the
Chinese consulate in Houston responded
by saying they were deeply shocked by
the erroneous comments on Hong Kong and
asked the Rockets to correct the error
Daryl Morey took down his tweet
and the Rockets tried to do damage
control apologize
despite the apology the government
canceled NBA broadcasts on Chinese state
TV sports channels has just announced
that it will suspend the broadcast of
any NBA games in China including this
week's preseason games
Tencent also suspended broadcasts of
Houston Rockets games in Shanghai
workers were tearing down advertisements
for upcoming games and fans protested
outside the stadium where teams were set
to play on social media a fan posted
this video of himself tearing up tickets
to the game in support of the Chinese
government the NBA commissioner stood
behind Morrie at a press conference held
values of the NBA are to support freedom
of expression and in this case daryl
morey as the general manager of the
Houston Rockets enjoys that right but
the league undercut their message when
journalists were stopped from asking
about the incident afterwards I just
wonder after the events of this week and
the fallout we've seen whether you would
both feel differently about speaking out
in that way in future foreign businesses
in China have long recognized that there
are red lines that must not be crossed
and traditionally those have been the
three teams Taiwan Tibet Tiananmen three
political issues the Chinese government
tries to control messaging around
companies have learned that if you cross
one of these lines there is a price to
pay for example in 2018 gap was selling
this t-shirt featuring a map of China
without Taiwan after a photo of the
shirt was posted online gap apologized
and promised to stop selling the
incomplete t-shirt in a statement
released by People's Daily a government
newspaper you're talking about a
one-party state that has the ability to
let you in to expel you to make you rich
by withholding access to consumers China
forces foreign companies to apologize
and or change their message in order to
continue selling products because China
has a population of 1.4 billion that
usually works
the MBA learned that doing business in
China means playing by their rules and
that's not what US leaders like
President Clinton had envisioned the
hope was that trade with China would
open it up to ideas of democracy and
free speech while making American
companies money at the same time but as
American companies changed their
messages to sell products in China the
risk became importing Chinese censorship
[Music]